there's an idea out there that 97% of
climate scientists agree that manmade
climate change is real I did a little
digging on this 97% and surprise
surprise depending on what websites you
go to and what sources you trust the
answer actually isn't so clear what is
clear for sure however is that the
overwhelming amount of climate
scientists the very experts in this
field do agree that the climate is
changing and it has something to do with
what humans are putting into our
atmosphere whether or not the exact
number is really ninety seven percent or
eighty six percent or 75 percent is
largely irrelevant the point is that the
vast amount of people who study this for
a living
believe it to be true we haven't
discussed a ton on climate change since
we've started the Rubin report but I've
said several times on the show that
since I'm not a scientist I have to go
on what the majority of scientists say
thus I accept manmade climate change as
fact I'm basing my belief on the best
information that I have in front of me
you don't just get to pick and choose
when you believe in science it either is
fact or it is not so if the vast amount
of scientists that are professionals in
this industry believe something to be
true then I have to base my opinion on
that rather than just guessing or hoping
or picking the random scientists that
see the world the way I want it to be at
the same time we should always be
skeptical of who funds what scientific
study if there are political aims behind
the research and especially if there's
money to be made by claiming something
as fact when the truth remains more
elusive a simple example of this of
course is that if a tobacco company
funded Studies on smoking in human
health we'd all be a bit more leery of
it than a truly independent study done
for purely research purposes so with all
this in mind I do believe from all the
people I've talked to such as dr.
Michael Mann the creator of the hockey
stick theory or my own science guru Cara
Santa Maria as well as the information
in front of me that man made
a change is real I also believe that the
national conversation around climate
change is mostly idiotic usually
vacillating between people who think
we're on the brink of a catastrophic
climactic disaster and those who hide
their head in the sand to the realities
of the changing environment like most
things and I always say this right the
answer is probably somewhere in between
and that's where we have to start having
these important conversations my guest
this week is the president for the
Center for industrial progress Alex
Epstein the center is a non-profit think
tank which believes in creating a new
industrial revolution through technology
to improve the planet
Alex's book the moral case for fossil
fuels lays out the argument that fossil
fuels have not only been an incredibly
positive and important piece for the
advancement of mankind but even now in
2016 they are still the best source of
energy for humans to make the most of
this world his book also tackles many of
the myths surrounding fossil fuels and
even has me challenging many of my own
assumptions of how much fossil fuels are
truly affecting the environment and if
we've demonized an energy source that
still has a lot of great potential to
help mankind now before I continue and
before people start freaking out let me
stop those of you who are going to say I
have rubens a climate change denier for
even talking to this guy now that really
is not the case but Who I am is someone
who is willing to have the provocative
and complex conversation that surrounds
it you guys know that I've made the show
about the Battle of ideas and Alex's
ideas are considered basically heretical
in some elite circles he's had a public
spat with Al Gore and he's been
subpoenaed in a lawsuit that the Justice
Department has brought against Exxon
Mobil even though he himself has done
nothing wrong
other than share his ideas in a truly
free society we must allow all ideas to
flourish because sunlight is the best
disinfectant if Alex's ideas are bad the
only way we can truly refute them is by
proving them to be so not by banning the
discussion altogether this is why the
Twitter
and of Milo you nopales a couple weeks
ago was so awful even if it was within
Twitter's right to do so surely Milo's
ideas weren't the worst of all the ideas
on Twitter but he had gained influence
that they couldn't control so they shut
him down while Nazi sympathizers and
Isis supporters remain there freely you
think Milo's ideas are bad yeah well
then use your voice on social media to
call them out on it you think Alex's
ideas are bad well then write a book
refuting them the risk we face is that
banning those who we disagree with and
suing those who say something we don't
like will eventually become the norm
this is why I think the new battle in
front of us is about authoritarians
versus libertarians people who want to
tell you how to think versus people who
want you to think on your own I think
you guys know which side I'm on and if
you're listening to this I think you're
right there with me
you